[موسيقى]
مع دخول شهر رمضان
تضاعفت عمليات التنقل من والى الحرم المكي
وداخلي مكه ما جعل القطاعات الامنيه
والخدميه تعمل على تنفيذ خطط منظومه النقل
العام حتى تضمن الانسيابيه والراحه
للمعتمرين والمصلين احنا الان مشاركين
تقريبا ب 2350 حافله وعلى استعداد انه
احنا نوفر وفق الخطه التشغيل المعتمده
3000 حافله لخدمه هذه المنظومه بشكل كامل
المعدل اليومي لنقل الركاب تقريبا من
مليون الى مليون و200 راكب تختلف ان 7
وتفاوتها ما بين ايام متوسطه الاسبوع
ونهايه الاسبوع خمس محطات نقل رئيسيه على
مداخل مكه التي تمكن المعتمرين والمصلين
من ايقاف مركباتهم واستخدام النقل العام
للوصول للحرم المكي
الى تسعه مواقف نقل داخليه تساهم في ايصال
المستفيدين من داخل مكه الى الحرم المواقف
الداخليه هي مواقف قريبه من الحرم
المده الزمنيه للنقل ما بيتجاوز العشر
دقائق من يوم ما يوقف سيارته الى ان يصعد
الحافله ومن ثم اتجاهه الى الحرم وابرزها
مواقف
ساحه كدانه هذه من ابرز المواقف بالاضافه
الى موقف الزاهر
وموقف دقمه الوبر في الجانب الاخر يعمل
مشروع حافلات مكه على تقديم افضل وسيله
للنقل العام عبر اثني عشر مسارا تغطي
الشوارع الرئيسيه والفرعيه والشوارع
الممتده بين الاحياء ويلعب دورا هاما في
تقليل اعداد السيارات في شوارع وطرقات مكه
في موسم العمره
من مكه المكرمه سلطان السلمي العربيه